hello everyone welcome back to collider
for another exclusive interview
this time around i am so pumped to get
to talk about
the babysitter sequel the babysitter
killer queen with two of the stars we've
got
judah lewis and emily allen lind here
hello and congratulations on another
wild ride with this franchise hello
hello thank you
so jude i wanted to start with you here
because i really love
going back to first features and kind of
getting a sense of how they might have
made an impression on you and our first
interview was for demolition and i was
looking back on it the other day oh
okay i was wondering what do you think
about from that experience and maybe
specifically what it was like for you
watching
jake work and how you can apply that to
being you know number one on the call
sheet with both of these babysitter
movies
completely yeah um there well
there's there's a couple pieces to that
um firstly
you know i think the biggest lessons
that i learned
uh through that film um were from
jean-marc vale
uh the director and also from jake and
you know
what what they're so brilliant at is
letting everything else go and being
fully present in the moment as your
character you know just really stepping
into their shoes stepping into their
thought process
and letting that play out and not coming
into scenes or situations with a
line reading or an intention but really
just letting it happen in the moment
um and in these babysitter movies uh
it's a very similar thing you know
they're so
wild and so crazy and so to just be
fully present there and experiencing
that
it's all you need and and not only that
but
one of the most fun things about
babysitter films are
it's so much improv it's so much of the
entire cast just
riffing off of each other and coming up
with things and
and so if you're just there existing as
your character
it it creates you know
this this kind of crazy environment um
but it also uh makes so much magic
that you would never come up with you
know in any other way
with this ensemble i would believe that
probably happens quite often
pretty much every take i'd say so emily
i do have an influence question for you
too but i'm going to save that for
later when we can get into it a little
more but you know just on the surface
here i was wondering what it was like
for you finding out that
one you were going to get to return for
another babysitter movie
but two that your role in the movie was
actually going to be kind of a driving
force of the narrative this time around
yeah is this our spoilers moment no not
yet save that
that's seriously your first reaction
yeah um
so so yeah it was great um we
we did the movie years and years ago and
uh
me and judah have sort of remained
friends uh since so it was really fun to
come back and reprise our roles
as adults and to sort of like see how
much our lives have changed but as well
as the characters
um i think that they both deal with
uh that night differently i think that
melanie sort of
wants to move on from it and cole is
still stuck inside of that night and
what and how it affects him but they
still have this amazing bond because
they both went through something
so terrible together and no one else
believes him except melanie so
it was really fun to uh to reprise our
roles and get back into it
i can't wait to like get to the spoiler
section but first
one of my favorite things about these
movies are the movie references so i was
wondering between the two films
is there any movie that you had never
seen before
that you had to watch because of the
script and you wound up falling in love
with it
there were actually two for me uh the
first of which was the graduate which i
don't know how i had never seen
um but there's a lot of through lines
yeah there's a lot of through lines with
that
um and then the second one is the sure
thing which
is a rob reiner john cusack movie um
and there's a whole scene in um
with mine in phoebe's character which
starts out with a whole deliverance
reference
um but then my character goes on this
whole uh
little monologue sort of thing in order
to save phoebe
and that entire thing is this really
kind of beautifully crafted homage to um
to a scene in the sure thing
i think that might be one of my favorite
scenes in this whole movie oh yeah
are you just watching that clip and kind
of listening to his intonation over and
over in order to kind of
nail it perfectly literally exactly
yeah and and it's really fun because
mcgee's the kind of director where
you know i think in every scene of this
movie there are
little nods and homages to different
films but it'll be the kind of thing
where
you know before when we're doing
rehearsals before we film any scene
you know mcgee's coming up with it with
his phone like guys i gotta show you
this
you know uh and it's some scene or some
little clip of some
random movie that you know maybe only
mcgee knows about
um but somehow it like gets held up the
product
we have like the first ad being like gee
we gotta keep on schedule and it's
literally like us watching
like a 30-minute clip from something
to be able to be on i mean yeah
completely but i think it adds it adds
so much to the film because whatever
that is
represents the exact tone or the vibe or
a certain aspect of the scene that he's
trying to emulate
um and that's the really fun thing about
this movie is like for attentive viewers
it really is a film that like you could
watch a couple times
and each time pick up more and more
easter eggs
it's so true that's that's part of the
reason why over the last couple of years
i've revisited that first one over and
over and over
so in talking about the ensemble here
which is another
one of my favorite things about these
movies i've got some cast
superlatives for you guys right now so
just tell me who kind of
best suits the answer to this question
and then maybe why
so we know that uh there are some pretty
extreme characters on the cult side who
of
all of those cast members would you say
can turn it on the quickest
they're all pretty great at doing that
which is really fun to watch them
fell back into their characters because
i don't could never see anyone else but
them playing those characters
they're so wacky um i think that
i mean i always say batch just because
he can just turn
turn any character on in an instant and
kill it
really um he's just so fun to watch
he's always improvising and that what do
you think judah
i know i'm i think that i couldn't have
said it better myself i think that's a
perfect
uh you could just like go on a rant
just can like i don't know where he's
pulling it out of but like he could just
go on a complete
rant about any subject and make it the
most hilarious
moment of the entire problem with
working with him though you just can't
keep a straight face
and you'll never never be able to to
beat him or
be on the same level it's just too funny
so
i have a feeling that probably answers
this question too but who's who's the
most likely to kind of catch you off
guard or surprise you with their improv
although wild chris wilde i know he's
not
he's not a part of the cult but chris
wilde is something else
yeah they're my one of my favorite
scenes it was kind of
cut a little bit too uh probably for
timing and stuff like that but like it
was batch and chris wilde and they like
meet
and they're walking to the house or
whatever and
they had they just like that scene i
remember
watching it being filmed and they just
like literally had
mickey never called cat because it's
just too brilliant i want that footage
and it's just like every single time
that they were walking with each other
it was meant to be like a hey bro hey
bro
it ended up being like this the best
like
dialogue back and forth completely
improvised they're amazing together
they're my favorite
this kind of falls outside of my little
superlative game here but i am curious
i always like hearing about a director's
tell
behind the monitor when they're really
feeling a take so what does
mkg do behind the monitor when you guys
are really like crushing a scene
oh he tells you about it yeah i know but
he'll also
when i see him when you can't see them
you know when they're behind the monitor
and you're in the scene
but if i see him like i'll see like a
judas scene with jenna or something like
that and i'll be at the monitor
and i'll just he'll be completely
completely zoned into it
like yes yes yes yes
like it's so fun to see oh
and then the first video will be like
should we call that no
no and a lot of scenes i don't even know
like i want a director's cut
because so many of these scenes just
would like he just lets you have it like
you can go
some of them are like 40 minutes long if
they weren't cut i would totally watch
all of that if they ever release that
your favorite so back to the cast here
who are the cast would actually have a
fighting chance to survive a night with
the cult
if they encounter them oh judah i think
judah would i
i really do he's such a little boy scout
i mean
honestly judah i was talking about this
before but judah
that we had this one scene when you know
all the cult members are come back and
you're in the hat we're in the house
boat
and for the wide of that scene
they didn't cut it was like uh like a
birdman moment or something where they
literally
it was just following each cult member
coming coming in and
uh actually mcgee held the camera for
one of the takes and and
and totally uh followed everyone but
judah every single one of those takes
that he had
was just lunging on the floor and
lunging back
and like bruising his legs and we were
feeding him like i was
we had this obsession with red bull for
some reason and bangs on on
on this side because it was all in night
shoots because we wouldn't rap filming
them every day i remember me and judah
we're at the we're at the
uh the high school we're shooting some
of the beginning scenes and me and judah
really wanted to drink the those bang
those bang energy drinks
we were so tired for the night before we
were shooting we were doing a daisy
and so we literally walked on one of our
breaks we took our entire lunch break
and walked to 7-eleven in this random
sketchy neighborhood
to get bangs but yeah but judo is just
like
judah will do any of his own stunts he's
obsessed with it i think that he would
survive tonight
i since i can't thank myself uh my pick
would i think be robbie mel because
here are my two reasons one the dude is
built like a greek god
i mean it's it's insane and secondly
so we were filming out on this lake
right and
um it was probably like 30 or 40 degrees
every night
and there was just the most
chilling crosswinds and everybody was
just
absolutely freezing and we were all like
huddled together in these warming
jackets between every take and like
and i swear robbie amell had to
jump into this lake for a take
and um i honestly i still don't know how
he did it
um but the dude's a warrior he also fell
off in the scene that there that he's on
he's on the uh robbie's on the uh tube
on the back of the boat and he has no
shirt on the entire film as well
um and he's holding on and he literally
felt like that he fell off
fell into the lake it was all worth it
his scenes are great in this
i know it's time i'm doing it right now
we're gonna go full-blown spoilers for
the babysitter
right now and i i mean emily you know
i'm coming right for you with this so
this is your last warning i'm gonna
start to spill the spoilers out now
please go check out the movie on netflix
if you haven't yet september 10th go
watch it then come back
and you can pause this and actually come
back and it'll start right here
so first question i have for you is
did you ever put much thought into what
melanie was going to do next
after filming the first movie and how
did that compare to
the spin they actually put on it for the
finished film
yeah no i i mean when i was reading the
script for the first time
um i mikji i had a meeting with mcgee
and he was talking about how you know he
didn't want to give
too much away but he was like i just
want you to read the script tell me what
you think and so i read it and i was
like
what the actual [ __ ] like i really did
not think that that would happen i mean
it's probably
the biggest turn that you could imagine
right um and i think that that's why it
was really important for us to get it
right
and um i hope we pulled that off for the
viewers i was
i was very i was very caught off guard
initially
i was very impressed by how well you
handled it so two
two influence questions for you now i
promised i'd come back to that first
is there anything that you watched uh
samara do on the first film
that you took into account here for your
own spin on it
yeah i think that it was important to
i think that samara kept a really calm
and collected
uh sort of the entire first film
um and i think she was very satanic
but also at the same time pretty sexy um
which is hard to pull off i i wanted to
make sure that melanie
seemed like she was trying i mean it's
obviously like her influence was
samara's character b
um and you know in the end when you find
out that she's
only doing this for followers it's
pretty pathetic and her character in the
end is pretty [ __ ] pathetic
um but i did i did need i did pull from
you know
the influence of samara just because i
think that uh
i think that melanie was definitely
influenced by v
another one i have for you because i
believe you shot this movie right before
i'm a huge dr sleep
fan thank you and i love rebecca
ferguson so so much
and you know she is kind of like a cult
leader with the true not there
so is there anything you saw her do in
on that movie on that set that you could
apply here i mean
rebecca is one of my favorite people
i've ever worked with
i think that she is one of the best
actresses out there
um i think that i pull i pull from i
mean i've been working since i was three
years old
um and i'm constantly learning from
people around me but working with
rebecca
i i totally found this new sense of
understanding uh acting
and i think i'll take uh her
i think i'll take the lessons i learned
from her everywhere i go
um for the future and definitely
yeah i mean she's the uh i feel like
she's the og cult leader i don't think
anyone can see it like her i mean her in
that film is my favorite of all time
i would i would not uh argue if there
was ever a true knot movie in the future
i feel like there are so many little
pieces to andy's story that i wanted
more of
yeah i mean if you read the book as well
that's so good so many little details
and
you know they tried they tried your best
but you only get like
two and a still long film but i
definitely think there's a lot to
explore there as well
and mike did it well i'm just greedy
because i love the book so much
i know i love another one too i love
that so
judah having dealt with you know so much
of this
the first time around when emily kind of
got her hands a little dirtier with the
blood and all the gore and all that
stuff did you have
any advice that could kind of help her
out with dealing with that
it's very sticky that's really the main
thing
i think everybody underestimates like
yeah no
when you get covered in fake blood like
it's there to stay for a little
for a little while it's definitely one
of those things where like the next week
you're just like you know
finding random blood and oatmeal and
pieces of strawberry and whatever
we just did a like a little uh session
where we learned how to apply
one wound to our faces and i think i was
finding like little pieces of latex and
like droplets of blood
all over the place for like a solid week
after that yeah
yeah so imagine like the max kill you
know where it's just like
brains on your face that that that's the
way
that's the most intense of all of it
because it's supposed to be chunky
you know so there's all these just
random it's literally like strawberries
and oatmeal and like things like that
but um you're definitely you're
definitely finding it for weeks so i
assume it's all like
it's all safe to eat and like not
concerned about it getting in your eyes
it's really funny to see hair and makeup
and special effects on how they talk
about this blood
they make it themselves and the way that
they explain it is like
there's aloe and there's like these
proteins that are perfect for your skin
and it's like all this stuff and it's
it's really so fascinating to see
they're like
they're so good at making it but it's
like actually this like basic
like if you put it on your face it'd be
like the best
nutritional mask you could do for
yourself that's a new face
face care regimen guys yeah exactly
through fake blood on your face
and it's perfect for the season like
netflix should box that stuff up and
send it out to everyone
i would try it um what about just the
set pieces overall here now that we
could talk about spoilers
is there any particular kill or set
piece that on set you guys were just
going like holy [ __ ] i can't believe
this is what it takes to pull this off
they had to make an entire fake body for
bella because of that
whole canyon scene with the polling and
then also what happens afterwards
there's a boulder that falls
and then her let one of her legs is used
to block an axe it's just a whole
progression um but uh
it's honestly scary like how
life-like those body parts are like
really
because i pick it up to block you know
max's axe
and i'm telling you like so it's a
little weird it's a little weird it
feels
kind of like a leg like you're like okay
you know
um and yeah no it's got like the same
weight and the mass and they have this
like fake skin on there
it's it's really unbelievable i don't
know how
how they pull it off how they make them
but it's it's absolutely incredible
this is why uh makeup effects and
prosthetics just
fascinate me to no end i don't know how
they do it yeah
yeah i don't know one i guess um if we
make another one i'll have to just like
go around and
sit and watch them because it really is
like the most fascinating things
how about doing the the ending scene
where
i mean they don't they don't explode but
have either of you seen
um uh ready or not
uh yes actually because like samara's in
both movies and they both kind of end
with people
or evaporating in a way so emily what
was it like
doing that effect for that final
showcase there
oh it was really fun another reference
mcgee was giving us is a game of thrones
reference this clip from
the red party um for how uh
someone i don't remember the character's
name but he they drink something it's
poisoned and he's just like
full out doing this entire um yeah i've
had some practice with stuff like that
before
uh reference dr sleep in a sense um
yeah i mean it's absolutely embarrassing
in the moment
you're there's nothing going on and it's
just like
action and you're all just
[ __ ] you know what i mean it's the most
important thing and yeah
i'm just standing there watching like
good job guys this huge scream at the
end when i die
and it's like yeah but uh it looks good
now
so it was well worth it for the final
product
my last one here is for you you've
already said the babysitter three so
maybe we can will it into existence
but you know given given where things
end do you think cole and his mind has
kind of closed the book or is he
permanently
attached to this cult and what they've
done where he's going to have to kind of
like lead the charge if someone else
finds the book again
well that's the thing i think that uh
he's now
kind of proven himself as this
you know uh killer of demons um
and so i'm sure that if there were you
know more of them out there
um and more of them who found this book
that he would be
the first in line to shut that down
um but i also think you know he's got to
finish high school
um i think that there's a lot of like
him and phoebe's relationship
you know that i'd love to further
explore and where that goes
as well as you know in in the end in the
final scene we finally see
you know him and his dad able to kind of
reconnect and find an
understanding for each other um and so i
think that would be another really
interesting thing i'm wondering what
happens there like
now the dad believes it will the mom
believe it like whoever
what i mean it's weird it could even be
a good idea to have a father and son
team where the mom still doesn't believe
okay now we're on to something we have
some
and then obviously the book can bring
everybody back all over again so we're
all set we got a good story let's make
this happen
you know once satan involved is involved
everything's up in the air really
exactly thank you guys so much for your
time today and again huge congrats on
the movie
it is uh it's wild to say the least
all over again thank you guys so much
thank you